- Did you know that the spelling bee
was invented in the United States?
Yeah, that's not a flex.
Spelling bees are kind of
pointless outside English,
because most other languages
have spelling systems
that are regular and predictable,
but English spelling is such a mess
that just being able to do it correctly
can earn you a trophy.
These two words rhyme,
but these two don't.
These two words rhyme.
These two don't.
These two rhyme, but these two don't.
In fact, none of these words
rhyme with any of the others.
English is full of these contradictions,
making it one of the
hardest languages to learn.
Almost every spelling rule
comes with a long list of exceptions.
I before E except after C.
Yeah, well, what about these?
Weird, huh?
An E at the end of the word
supposedly makes the vowel long,
like in home and hive and hate.
Well, I'd love for someone to give me
an explanation for these.
Many letters can have multiple sounds,
and others seem to serve
no purpose whatsoever.
A K in knife, an H in
ghost, an S in island?
In fact, almost every
letter of the alphabet
is silent somewhere.
Yeah, I got the receipts.
Some have accused English spelling
of being irrational and
arbitrary, but, actually,
there are good reasons why
our spellings are so strange.
Well, some good reasons,
some snobby reasons,
and some that are downright dum-buh.
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky
and this is "Other Words".
(curious music)
- "Other Words".
- English's wacky spelling
goes all the way back
to the origin of the alphabet.
Old English was a Germanic
language spoken by Anglo Saxons
who used a runic alphabet
known as a Futhorc.
As Latin missionaries
Christianized England
during the seventh century,
they replaced the Futhorc
with the Latin alphabet.
The thing is the Latin alphabet
was not designed for a Germanic tongue.
There were sounds that Anglo Saxons used
that had no equivalent in Latin.
This required some improvisations.
Some letters had to do
double duty, like C,
which stood for [k], as in macian
and [ch], as in circe,
and a couple runic
letters were kept around,
like wynn, which signified the [w-] sound
and thorn, which made the [th] sound.
As you can see, the English
alphabet had barely begun
and it was already
getting a bit confusing.
But plenty of other non-Latin languages
use the same alphabet, like
German, Dutch, and Czech,
and their spellings,
while not exactly easy,
are at least consistent.
So how did English spelling
get so uniquely screwed up?
(cheerful music)
In 1066, William the Conqueror
invaded England from Normandy
and installed French
speaking nobles to rule it.
Not only did they bring a ton
of French words with them,
but the Norman scribes
changed the spelling
of a lot of English words
to look more familiar to French readers.
One of the first things they did
was get rid of those pesky runic letters.
They replaced the thorn with
T-H and the wynn with two Us,
which eventually became,
what do you know, W.
In French, the ooh sound was spelled O-U,
as in crouton and rouge,
so old English words like
hus and hund had Os added.
The French used G-H to
signify the [kh] sound,
so the old English words
niht and miht had Gs added.
By the time the Normans
were done tinkering with it,
the Middle English spelling
system was already a jumble
of Germanic, Latin,
and French conventions,
but two big events in linguistic history
were about to make
things much, much worse.
Between 1400 and 1700,
the pronunciations of many
English vowels shifted.
No one knows exactly why this happened,
but it's essentially what created
the modern English sounds we use today.
For instance, the [oo] sound became [ow],
so hoose and hoond became house and hound.
[Ah] became [eh], so nah-meh became name-eh.
[Ee] became [ai], so lee-keh became like-eh.
A lot of words lost their
second syllables altogether,
so name-eh and like-eh
became name and like.
We still commemorate that second
syllable with the silent E.
Other consonant sounds faded away as well.
Dum-buh became dumb.
Ni-kht and li-kht became night and light.
Keh-nife and keh-nikht
became knife and night.
You might be thinking,
if you're not gonna
pronounce the sounds anymore,
why not get rid of the extra letters?
Well, some scholars at the time
did want to update the spelling system
to match the new pronunciations,
but something was happening concurrently
that would lock in those
outdated spellings permanently.
(playful music)
Around 1440, Johannes Gutenberg
invented the printing press in Germany,
and within 100 years, it had
spread all across Europe.
In England, this meant that spellings
had to become standardized
right at the time
that pronunciations were shifting.
Moreover, the people who
did the standardizing
didn't always have the best reasons.
Dutch type setters changed some spellings
to match their Flemish conventions,
like adding an H to ghost and ghastly.
And since dumb ended with a B,
some printers mistakenly added
Bs to limb, crumb, and numb,
an error known as hypercorrection.
There was also a lot of snobbery going on.
By now, the Renaissance was in full swing,
and scholars were importing
tons of fancy words
from Greek, Latin, and French
with their fancy spellings.
These were derogatorily
known as "inkhorn words,"
named for the ink pots
that nerds and know-it-alls
kept on their desks.
As if that wasn't bad enough,
the Renaissance fanboys also
wanted to change the spellings
of existing English words
to pay tribute to their
etymological roots.
Words of Greek dissent were signified
by adding an H after the C,
as in chronicle and chaos,
and substituting P-H for F,
as in physics, phlegm, and pharmacy.
And words of Latin origin,
like det, dout, sine,
receit, indite, and ile had letters added,
not to be pronounced, but
just as a reminder to readers
where those words originally came from.
In another instance of hypercorrection,
they even added an S to the word island,
mistakenly believing it was
related to the word isle.
In fact, the two words have
totally different origins.
Classic case of over-nerding.
The end of the great vowel shift
represents the beginning
of modern English,
but thanks to the printing press,
it was stuck with a spelling system
that was based on Germanic roots
with a Latin script using French spellings
to describe Middle English pronunciations.
Some have attempted to
modernize English spelling,
most notably Noah Webster,
who in the early 1800s
suggested a bunch of
phonetically corrected changes.
Some stuck, others did not.
This list kind of reminds me
of the recent trend in phonetic spelling
popularized by texting and social media.
Though it's typically employed
for humor and brevity,
it does speak to an underlying desire
for our written language
to more closely match our spoken one.
While it may seem
far-fetched that dictionaries
would ever make these things official,
stranger things have happened.
Until then, we can at least take comfort
knowing that our spelling
quirks are evidence of language
that is uniquely flexible,
absorbent, and multicultural.
And that we live in
the age of spell-check.
I take great comfort in spell-check.
Ni-ght and li-ght.
More phlegm, ni-ght,
ni-ght, ni-ght and li-ght.
Ni-ght and, I can't.
Ni-ght, keh-ni-ght.
I never have to say ni-ght again.